many cloud native development teams work
with a mix of configuration systems
apis and tools to manage their
infrastructure
this mix is often difficult to
understand leading to reduced velocity
and expensive mistakes
let's look at how alice uses config
connector
for consistent gcp resource management
alice is a new engineer preparing for
her first on-call
she is also worried about having to
learn new commands to make configuration
changes
using specialized tools to solve a
plethora of problems is one of the
benefits
of the linux and microservices
approaches
but it also comes with added complexity
of having to learn
many tools to do often similar tasks
many times it turns out that these
separate components
would have been served if they allowed
you to express what you want to do
without having to focus on the specific
api to make it happen
luckily alice has a lot of experience
with k-8 tool chains
she discovers that using config
connector cloud resources are managed
consistently with k-8s
native resources like pods and services
alice realizes that she can fully
operate the cloud using
her existing k8 expertise and get ops
and that's the benefit of config
connector config connector is a
kubernetes add-on
that allows you to manage google cloud
resources through kubernetes manifests
because you can manage your google cloud
infrastructure the same way you manage
your kubernetes application
complexity and cognitive load is reduced
for developers
this means more focus where it matters
on the infrastructure
config connectors provide a collection
of kubernetes custom resource
definitions
crds and controllers the config
connector crds allow kubernetes to
create and manage google cloud resources
like a cloud sql database the same way
kubernetes developers are used to
applying kubernetes objects to their
clusters
you configure and apply objects to your
clusters
since alice is already familiar with
kubernetes tooling
and declarative workflow she is able to
use
her existing expertise to quickly ramp
up and manage the customer's workload
let's see a quick example of this in
action
alice wants to create a storage bucket
to store images
the first step is to create a resource
definition
which uses yaml to specify the storage
bucket's information
like its name and what project it's
associated with
this resource can be updated through the
kubernetes api
by updating the storage buckets yaml
file
in this case alice added a label to the
bucket and annotation to specify
other behaviors on your storage bucket
running the familiar
coop ctl commands we already know and
love like
coupe ctl apply in this case we can
create the storage bucket
now instead of having to learn another
tool like the gsutil tool
alice was able to use the knowledge she
already had to create her storage bucket
all these changes were done through the
kubernetes epi which means alice could
apply the expertise she's already built
up over time
without having to learn new tools to
manage infrastructure
that's one of the benefits of managing
gcp resources
with config connector in combination
with config sync
you also ensure the change process is
consistent through git ops
removing the risk of config drift
so that's it for config connector make
sure to check out the description for
links to more resources on it
and like and subscribe to the channel
for more videos about google cloud
thanks for watching
you